My dear grandchildren,
when I was your age,
the sea was already at the centre of my life.
Growing up in Malta the blue Mediterranean is everywhere.
The sea is very much a part of the family.
It’s our past,
our present,
our future.
I am the European Commissioner for Environment, Maritime Affairs and Fisheries,
that means that it is my job to protect nature,
to protect fish and other marine animals,
but also to help the fishermen, the sailors,
and all people who live from the sea,
to ensure that we benefit from the rich resources of the sea
whilst preserving them for future generations
… for you.
The sea is facing more and more dangers.
In some areas, we fish too much.
Plastic fills up our oceans.
Our planet is getting warmer
with damaging effects on life in the oceans.
We can solve all these problems,
working together.
And that is why I am both proud and hopeful
when this year in October hundreds of world leaders, politicians, ocean lovers
will gather together in our island of Malta.
To find the solutions
and to take the concrete commitments
to act for cleaner, for safer and for healthier seas.
Dear grandchildren my ocean is your ocean.
My ocean, is our ocean.